>>Lars Bak: Good morning, and welcome to the
second day of Google I/O. I hope you all enjoyed
the party yesterday with Billy Idol.
[ Laughter ]
>>Lars Bak: Yeah. From my youth.
>>Lars Bak: So we want to talk about web programming
languages and virtual machines and we're trying
to argue why it's important to always make
it faster so that you guys can make better
applications.
I'm Lars Bak. I'm the blue guy. And this is
Kasper Lund --
>>Kasper Lund: I'm the red guy.
>>Lars Bak: -- the red guy.
[ Laughter ]
>>Lars Bak: And we are from Google, from the
Danish engineering office, so if we look tired,
it's jet lag.
All right. So just to know -- so you know
who we are, we've been working on virtual
machines for too long. I started in '86, and
in '86 working on virtual machines for their
programming languages was sort of a little
bit niche, and it was only research communities
that had an interest in it.
But given today we have several hundred people
here, I'm pleased that there's more interest
for it.
So I started working with Kasper 13 years
ago and we've been doing Java virtual machines,
Smalltalk virtual machines, JavaScript virtual
machines, and now Dart, so we sort of have
a little bit of experience in doing compilers
and garbage collectors, so hopefully we can
tell you about some of our findings over the
last many years.
So why are we here? We're here because we
truly believe that speed in web browsers fuel
innovations for application developers, right?
The more speed we can give you, the more interesting
applications you can do. And we strongly believe
in the fly-by web, right? Developers do one
application -- it runs on mobile phones and
desktop systems -- and this is just fantastic.
And the source that makes it work is the virtual
machine inside the browser.
And if we can make it faster, you can take
advantage of it.
The question is, we have seen a lot of speedup
in browsers over the last, I guess, five years.
Is it fast enough or do we want more speed?
So we are of the opinion that we need to do
even better, and that is one of the reasons
why we have started on this new venture to
do a Dart platform.
>>Kasper Lund: So before we dive into the
technical details of virtual machines and
programming for the web, I just wanted to
take you back to 2006 when we started developing
V8. At that point, Web pages had evolved from
being fairly static to being a little bit
more rich, and we were seeing sort of the
first Web applications appear. At the point
in time, you were probably running Firefox
2.0, Internet Explorer 7.0, or some other
browsers there, but it was very clear that
these browsers were not really designed for
long-running, heavy Web applications. They
were designed for the web of two thousand-
-- well, probably 2000, yeah.
And so it was an interesting at that point
in time, 2006, it was just before we were
seeing these applications really come to life
on the web. And even if you -- if you look
at the Web sites I've depicted up here, you
can tell the difference, if you can actually
see it from the back of the room, that in
2008, already then we were seeing pages like
BBC becoming a little bit more interactive
and more rich.
So in 2006 when we set out to implement a
new virtual machine for JavaScript for the
web, people believed that browsers were essentially
fast enough. Web applications like Gmail and
Google Maps ran fine and people were very
impressed with them. People also believed
that JavaScript was just inherently too slow
for writing heavy client-side computations.
And even so, people didn't really expect the
JavaScript to improve that much so they didn't
think that the execution of JavaScript was
holding things back. They were okay with having
more code running on the server side and having
fairly limited amounts of logic on the client
side.
Another key thing for us when we started was
that performance at that point was evaluated
using very simple micro-benchmarks, where
all the emphasis was put on simple loops with
very simple arithmetic and nobody paid any
attention to the overhead for calling methods
or how large applications would perform when
it comes to memory management.
So people were really spending all their time
looking at small, simple loops and trying
to make them run a little bit faster.
So here's an example of a benchmark that I
think represents that line of thought pretty
well.
This is a benchmark, a JavaScript benchmark,
from the SunSpider benchmark collection. It's
known as "bit-wise and" and that's all it
does. It computes the bit-wise and for a series
of values here, starting out with a fairly
large number and then it runs through a loop
and you'll probably notice that even on the
iteration, I is zero so when you "and" that
with anything, you'll get zero out. So this
is just a fancy way of computing zero.
Not exactly something you want to spend a
lot of time on optimizing for, I guess, and
certainly not something that would, if you
actually did optimize this, it would turn
your application any faster.
So SunSpider is a benchmark that sort of represents
some of the things and some of the problems
from sort of the earlier web, and they -- it
is being updated every now and then but not
with any significant differences. This is
from SunSpider 1.0 released a couple of weeks
ago. It's very nice to see that they've added
testing that actually does compute zero but
it's still a really bad benchmark. Making
this faster and tuning V8 for these kind of
things would not make your applications run
any faster, so...
So when we started designing V8, we had to
make a choice. Like what do we want to optimize
for?
And there are basically two approaches.
You can optimize for the current apps and
the current benchmarks, and that's a nice
and simple incremental approach, and there's
a good chance you can make things 10%, maybe
20% faster that way. And we chose to optimize
for the apps of the future at that point so
we decided that we wanted to support much
heavier side client-side computations and
we wanted to turn the browser into a scalable
application platform, sort of thus enabling
a new class of Webapps that could be written.
So optimizing a brand-new virtual machine
for some applications that you cannot write
-- or you couldn't write in 2006 -- required
us to come up with some benchmarks and some
metrics that would allow us to make progress
on that problem.
Which is where the V8 benchmark suite entered
the game.
So the V8 benchmark suite is a collection
of benchmarks that are structured and mostly
object-oriented, and they're designed to push
the limits of browsers in 2006 but also today,
and it's benchmarks that are mostly proven
valuable in the context of lots of other languages.
So it's benchmarks that we know that if we
optimize for those, it will actually make
it possible for you guys to write much larger
and much more interesting applications.
It measures the performance of dynamic message
calls and property access and it also measures
the performance of the memory management system,
and closure creation and location, to a much
higher degree than any of the existing benchmarks
in 2006.
>>Lars Bak: But Kasper, can I get the mic?
Thank you. Let's try to run it so we can see
how it looks.
So here, let's search for the V8 benchmark
suite and we can run Version 7 of it, and
it will start running and you'll see the results
trickling in on the right-hand side and you
can see the collection of benchmarks we are
running. It's eight different benchmarks.
They're not big, but they are certainly not
micro-benchmarks.
And we should soon have the results.
The interesting part is that the score you
see is computed as the geometric mean between
individual scores but it's calibrated for
Firefox 2 on a high-end desktop machine in
2008.
So we are pretty much running 160 times faster
than one of the browsers in 2008, so this
is pretty amazing.
>>Kasper Lund: Yeah. The score was 100 on
Firefox 2 on my beefy desktop machine in 2008.
It's a little bit better now. Which is nice.
[ Laughter ]
>>Kasper Lund: So I think it's fair to conclude
that the performance improvements for JavaScript
over the last eight years have been pretty
impressive. JavaScript itself executes a hundred
times faster than it did before, at least,
and we see people being able to write applications
that use way bigger object heaps, and the
GC pauses are even lower than they were at
that point.
Another key thing for us as compilers and
VM engineers is that people pay attention
now to performance of their Webapps and it's
very, very common to see benchmark numbers
reported in the press, so it's a -- there's
a nice friendly competition going on to improve
the web platform performance.
Another thing that's very nice to see is that
it's possible to write really large Webapps
these days. We see common pages like Amazon,
CNN, and ESPN have -- they're serving fairly
large amounts of JavaScript codes to their
customers all day, so it's not uncommon to
see like a megabyte of JavaScript code, minified
JavaScript code, being sent to clients. And
the browsers are generally capable of working
with that. So things have certainly changed
since 2006.
One thing that is important for us is to pay
attention to where the time is actually spent
in your browser, and what you have here is
a couple of diagrams that show that we're
spending around 60% of the time in JavaScript
execution when you're running things like
Gmail, Google Docs, Google Search, and things
like that, and the rest is spent in the general
browser infrastructure.
On other sites like Twitter and Facebook,
the percentage in JavaScript is a little bit
lower than that. And these measurements are
all done by the Chrome team using Chrome,
so we don't have the exact same numbers for
the other browsers. But it shows that no matter
how fast we make the engines, the application
developers will adapt to that and add new
functionality and essentially make their applications
better by using this thing.
So imagine how it would feel like running
modern Gmail on a browser from 2006. I don't
think you would like that at all.
So today, web developers are really pushing
the limits of the platform and they really
want and demand predictable high performance.
Higher and higher, actually.
They want consistent frame rates for their
games. And they really want to support large-scale
application development.
So people's expectations for this platform
have really changed. They really demand these
things now, and all it took is 100X performance
improvement. It makes a really, really big
change to the technology stack when you do
these things.
So the question is, of course, are the web
developers getting predictable and high performance,
and can they actually support really large-scale
application development on the current web
stack?
So before we answer that question, I think
we should dive into the -- the current web
stack and take a look at how we can improve
the parts.
>>Lars Bak: All right. Now we'll dive into
what actually happens inside the virtual machine
and the browser.
So I'll be talking about a few different techniques
we've been using to make V8 fast and I'll
talk about the history behind these technologies.
Firstly, let's look at a browser. So a browser
has several parts. But if we look at the performance-critical
part for a Webapp, it actually consists of
two segments.
At the lower part, we have the JavaScript
engine where you have all the code and the
objects and the WebObjects that point to the
DOM. The DOM consists of the -- the nodes
that you can see on the screen. And when you
execute your Web application, you manipulate
the DOM by executing JavaScript.
We all hope that when you develop a Web application,
you have low latency so it comes up fast and
there's no pauses, it has high performance,
and it also has low memory usage so you don't
end up swapping when you run your application.
And then, of course, more pauses if you do
animation. But there are still big fears when
you run a Web application, right?
If the object heap is too big, you can get
very large GC pauses, and you can have memory
leaks. So having a Web application that runs
for weeks and suddenly it runs out of memory
is not very pleasant for the user.
And sometimes you'll get erratic performance
behavior for no good reasons.
And this is sort of some of the issues people
are concerned about when writing for the web.
Here is my picture of how a virtual machine
or a JavaScript engine looked like in the
year 2006.
It had a simple parser that would take the
source code and convert into an abstract syntax
tree or into byte codes and then it would
have a simplistic interpreter that would run
over the AST, abstract syntax tree, or the
byte codes and execute the program.
And then it would have a simple memory management
system to clean out unused memory.
Now, in 2006 you would not create many objects
because you knew that if you created a lot
of objects, your program would be slow, so
you actually didn't use many of the object-oriented
qualities of the system.
So the conclusion is, it was very simple and
that's nice that you can write this kind of
VM in a few thousand lines, but the downside
was it was really slow.
Today, we have a sports car and I can guarantee
you we have put in all kinds of fancy turbo
engines in it to make it fast, right? We still
have a parser, but instead of an interpreter,
we have a multi-tier adaptive compilation
system. It's basically a -- it's a series
of compilers that learns from the behavior
of the program and tries to optimize the execution
based on behavior.
We have a de-optimization system that allows
the system to back out of optimization if
the behavior of the program changes over time.
And then we have a system that handles large
object heaps. And in the V8 case, we have
a generation-based garbage collector that
allows us to have heaps up to a gigabyte,
at least, where you can still have reasonable
pauses when running your program.
Native code is generated on the fly and is
generated by the buckets, I guarantee you,
and what will happen when it's not used anymore,
it will be removed by the garbage collector.
So even return addresses on the execution
stack will function like pointers into the
code, and if they are not used anymore, the
code will be eliminated.
And then of course there's all this tool sport
with debugging and profiling.
Because when you do optimizations -- right?
-- you sort of lose the understanding of what
the source code is doing, so you cannot single-step
an optimized code. It will give no meaning
to you.
So what we try to do is we try to de-optimize
the code. If we try to single-step, it will
look like you do single-stepping in the normal
source code. And that's great for a programmer,
because then you can debug on an odd-based
system or an intra-based system and get exactly
the same behavior.
It's really complex, but the good thing is,
it's fast.
Let's go beyond the hood and see what's going
on inside the V8 engine when it comes to a
few things.
I'll briefly mention how we make the code
really fast, and this is this multi-tier adaptive
compilation system.
I'll talk about how we handle large object
heaps by doing this generation-based garbage
collection with a twist.
And then I'll talk about how we bind JavaScript
objects to the DOM nodes.
And this is -- this is tricky, so I'm calling
it the tangoing between the tracing GC and
reference counting.
So listen up. This might be a little bit tricky
here.
When you parse the code, the code is blue.
You have a sea of JavaScript methods. Nothing
has been executed yet. When you start executing,
the first simplistic compiler will take the
source code and convert into native code,
right?
It doesn't know much about the behavior of
the program, so what it's doing is putting
in inline cache stops that tracks the behavior
of the program. So in essence, what it's doing
at one call site in the program, it tries
to figure out exactly what kind of type of
objects comes by.
At the same time, we have this monitoring
system in the system that detects when a method
is used frequently. If it's used frequently,
we said, "Well, let's try to optimize it even
further." And the optimizing native compiler,
what it will do, it will take the collected
type information from the inline caches and
use that to do aggressive inlining.
So it basically assumes that the behavior
of the program you had before you optimized
will be the same in all future. It's not always
the case, but we're optimistic here.
So we do these aggressive inlining decisions,
but we put in the optimization hook so that
if our assumptions are wrong in the optimized
code, we can go back again to the naive, simple
code.
In most cases, we don't have to do that and
you'll get the predictable performance, which
is great.
It gets even harder -- right? -- because as
you all know, there's no types in JavaScript,
and that means we have to do funky stuff.
One funky thing we are doing is that if you
use an array and you put doubles in it, at
some point at runtime we decide to optimize
it by converting the representation of an
object from an array that can have any kind
of objects to a representation that can only
have double values. Right?
So we assume that moving forward, we will
only operate on double values in this array.
That will certainly speed up programs that
continue to have that behavior, but you still
need the hooks if something from the side
would put in an integer. Or not an integer.
Let's say a -- a string in that array.
Then we have to back out of that optimization
and go back to the standard representation
of an object array. Very complicated.
But anyways, you have a system that's always
changing when you run it.
Did we invent this multi-tier adaptive compilation?
No, we are not that smart. There is actually
a long history of implementing dynamic languages,
started with interpretation in the '50s with
Lisp. In the '70s, we have dynamic compilation
being added to Smalltalk. And they even had
inline caching. It was not at the call side,
but they put it at the callee. So instead
of having it -- the method calling it, it
was actually at the prologue of the method
you called.
And then the adaptive compilation was invented
in the '90s in the sales project where you
have mixed mode execution, runtime-type feedback
and all this kind of stuff.
And then they also came up with deoptimization.
So let me try to explain what deoptimization
is. It is actually very simple.
When you have the optimized code and you have
activations on the stack that's executing
and you figure out that something is wrong,
you need to revert. What you do is you take
that optimized activation and convert it into
a series of unoptimized activity on the stack,
flush the optimized code, and start using
the simple code again.
This first appeared commercially in the HotSpot
JVM. I assume you all know about what that
is.
The other thing we did in V8 to basically
use all this technology was introducing behind-the-scenes
classes. You know that JavaScript is prototype-based,
but we faked them behind the scenes in event
classes. Then you can apply all this technology
on the slide, and that made it fast.
The garbage collector in V8 is here. It might
look complicated. We basically have two generations.
And the way it works is, as you are allocating
optics in your program, we will fill up the
allocation space. It is called "from" here.
When it is full, we will start a garbage collection
process. And we have a tracing garbage collector.
That means that we have well-defined routes,
and we start following these routes through
the optics, through its references until we
have computed the complete live optigraph.
And memory that's not occupied by the live
optigraph is garbage, and it can be reclaimed
and used for further objects.
Let's see what happens when you do a use-space
collection in V8. We migrate the optics to
the "to" space. And you can see it is smaller,
and that is because most optics die young.
And this is great.
Then we can start allocating and filling up
the "to" space and repeat the same story.
The garbage collector in V8 is a precise garbage
collector. It stops the world and processes
the garbage and then continues on.
You can see you have red pointers in the graph.
It denotes that the system has a stop buffer
that tracks pointers from old generation to
the new generation. And you need that if you
want to do fast use-space garbage collection.
You don't have to scan the whole heap in order
to do a small garbage collection.
The old space in V8 has been segmented into
normal optics. That's the optics that's promoted
from use-space when they have survived for
a while, and then native code where you have
native instructions, and then a segment where
you have atomic data. Atomic data is data
that does not have pointers out again. So
it could be typed arrays or double optics,
something like that. That is easier to handle
in a separate space because they don't have
pointers out.
Anyways, we didn't invent that either. Sorry.
There's a long history of automatic memory
management done in Lisp in the '50s. Incremental
garbage collection done in the '70s in Lisp
as well. And then you have generational-based
garbage collection that got invented by the
one guy in the '80s and generationally scavenged
any use of Smalltalk.
So all these techniques for doing garbage
collection is fairly simple in my mind because
you have all the pointers to the optics and
you can just process them.
The hard part is actually dancing with the
DOM. And I will try to tell you how that works.
So nodes in DOM is going by what we call reference
counting. Reference counting is a simplistic
garbage collection technology that keeps a
pointer in each optic that tells how many
pointers point to it. When that pointer goes
to zero, you can de-allocate the optic.
The problem is you don't know who points to
it. You just know how many. That means that
if you want to move the optic memory, you
cannot do that because you cannot find how
to point to it.
And another deficiency of that mechanism is
also if you have a cycle, which can happen,
then it's a memory leak because you will never
get down to zero in the reference count.
And the problem is JavaScript V8 has optics
that are traced and we have to get all this
to work.
So, here we go. Bear with me. This is complicated.
On the top you see the DOM. You have two nodes.
The first node has a reference count of 1.
The second one has a count of 2. And you have
wrapper optics that point to these DOM nodes
from beneath, and that is the V8 heap.
Now, in order to make sure you can collect
these optics, you have to make tricks. And
you can see you have this pairing between
JavaScript optics and DOM nodes by using repointers.
So, in essence, you have a JavaScript wrapper
that points to a DOM node that in turn points
to a persistent handle -- that's the black
ones -- that, in turn, will use a repointer
pointing back. So it is sort of a semicycle,
and you break the cycle by using repointers.
So that is simple.
But it gets even more complicated. When V8
is running out of memory and has to perform
a garbage collection, it has to call the DOM
and ask the DOM to group all objects that
belong together because that's needed in order
to only collect -- you basically have to collect
all grouped optics at the same time. That's
needed to avoid resurrection of wrapper optics.
That might seem complicated, but it is needed
because if you add a property to one of the
JavaScript nodes at the bottom and it suddenly
disappears and reappears again, the property
is gone and the application will get a little
bit confused. So we need to do all this in
order to make sure garbage collection works.
Did we invent this? Actually, that's the only
thing we did. It works. Chrome is great. But
that part we are not proud of. It needs a
lot more work in order to make sure that we
can guarantee that all memory is collected
the right way. But we will get back to this
later in this talk, what we are doing about
it.
Does this mean that V8 is as good as it gets?
Right? We have taken all these techniques
from the past, advanced codebase techniques
with hidden classes and sophisticated memory
management.
Is this what we have, or do we want more performance?
Well, from the feedback we're getting, there's
still a lot of bottlenecks in the browser.
Performance is not still at par with real
languages. You can define what "real" is your
own way. But I would sort of at least say
Java and C# as contenders.
Performance is still unpredictable. And you
can see if you do animation in the browser,
sometimes you skip frames. And part of it
is because you do too much compilation. Part
of it is because you do garbage collections.
Part of it is because you are deoptimized
because suddenly the assumption changed in
the program.
And in JavaScript, that's very easy to do
because just jamming a lot of property on
a hot object, bam, performance changes.
Startup is still slow. And the reason for
that is that you still have to read in the
source code whenever you have to start up
the program.
And, of course, JavaScript is still JavaScript.
There's a lot of implicit conversions of values
when you run JavaScript. It is just complicated.
So having said that, the V8 project is still
doing excellent. They are still improving
performance quarter after quarter. But we
think that if we really want to push the performance
to the next level, something else is needed.
Let's look at performance over time when it
comes to V8. This is a graph that shows the
V8 benchmark score from the different versions
of Chrome, all the way up to today.
And it's gone from 3,800 all the way up to
14,000. So it certainly has improved a lot.
So this is great. But there's a downside.
Here's the complexity over time of V8. And
we measure complexity by number of lines of
code in the VM.
When we came out of V8, it was roughly 100,000
lines of code. Now it's half a million lines
of code. And I don't know -- as a programmer,
you know that there's trouble when it gets
so big. It takes way more effort in order
to improve performance. So we question whether
that's possible to get a factor of 2 in V8
in the near time. You can follow the graph.
Factor of 2 will take a long time, unless
it is rewritten, of course. This also would
be a fun project.
>>Kasper Lund: So we've gone through a lot
of Web technology stuff here and looked into
how V8 works and why it is as fast as it is.
Let's dive into the Dart side and look at
how Dart improves this. So Dart is a simple
class-based unsurprising programming language.
It is designed to be very familiar so that
Web developers and application developers
can pick it up and learn to use it in no time.
We've got excellent feedback from users of
the system that this really works. You can
sit down and code in Dart. And within a few
hours, you feel like you are very productive
and it actually works out really well.
To hit that target of being very familiar,
we've designed it based on principles and
concepts found in other languages. So the
syntax is very much inspired by JavaScript,
Java, C#, those kind of languages. And we
get a lot of other value from essentially
standing on the shoulders of other good programming
languages out there and picking the things
that we feel are good fits for a language
that needs to be really efficient and at the
same time very productive.
One thing that we've added to Dart, which
is a little bit uncommon is support for optional
static types. That means that you can write
static-type notations where you want them,
where you feel like they convey the intent
that you want to convey. But you don't have
to put them in. The system is very flexible
that way. It doesn't require you, and it is
a fully dynamically typed system. It is hard
to describe this in one slide without showing
some code. So I will use two.
Here is a little bit of a taste of Dart. I
don't know how many of you are familiar with
Dart, tried it out. But for those of you who
are seeing it for the first time, I hope you
will find that this is reasonably readable.
It is a very simple example. It shows that
all Dart applications start with a main function.
And in this case, I just added a little bit
of an HTML interaction here. I am creating
a new button element, adding that to the document
body, and giving it a bit of text.
Hopefully, you can read this code if you are
familiar with JavaScript, C#, Java, those
kind of languages and it doesn't feel too
foreign for you. That's exactly what we wanted
to try to get at.
One thing that might look a little bit different
here is the import, and it just shows that
Dart has support for modularity. So you can
import libraries of functionality and code
and use that. So we do have a namespacing
mechanism and a way of carving up your application
in multiple independent bits. So I hope this
seems reasonably easy to read for you guys.
I think a good question to ask at this point
is: What are we trying to achieve with Dart?
And we feel that there is a need for a much
more scalable development platform for Web
apps. We feel like it is too costly and too
difficult to write great Web apps. You can
achieve amazing things on the Web today, but
you really have to invest a lot of time in
it. Things are getting better, but we feel
like we need something like Dart to push the
limits of this and make it much, much easier
to write large, well-functioning applications.
We think there is a real need for higher performance
and much faster startup. And we certainly
feel like having predictable performance where
it's harder to write applications that really
perform poorly because of somewhat weird semantics
in the core of the system that you're building
on is a must.
Another thing that we consistently hear from
users of Dart and other systems is that having
great toolability, being able to write tools
and use tools on your codebases for refactoring,
editing, and just maneuvering around, navigating
your code is a great big help. And the static
types that we have, even though they are optional,
they are a big help here, to just document
your intent of your code and make use of it.
And, finally, I think it is very important
for us that we make it easy and nice to use
a set of consistent libraries and make it
easy for the community to create new libraries
and share them in the same way. Certainly
an area where the Web suffered a little bit.
We see great things out there written for
JavaScript, but it is not necessarily trivial
to make things fit together if you have multiple
independent pieces of JavaScript functionality
you want to bring together. We are trying
to make that better with Dart, so that's what
we are trying to achieve.
Clearly, we want Dart to be useful in all
browsers, all modern browsers. So we've written
a translator that translates Dart code to
JavaScript that runs in all modern browsers.
That translator itself is actually written
in Dart, so we are trying to dogfood our own
product here. And that has been great experience
for us, to write a fairly significant amount
of code in Dart, translate -- in a translator
that translates Dart to JavaScript can actually
translate itself so you can take that big
piece of code and translate it to JavaScript
and then you have a Dart-to-JavaScript translator
in JavaScript. That's kind of neat. It runs
across all modern browsers. That's a big one
here.
So the users that actually try using Dart
are fairly happy with some of the decisions
we've made. And Thomas from an Austrian startup,
Blossom, describes this fairly accurately
in one of his quotes here. He says that Dart
is exactly what he needs to be productive
on the Web. So the feedback that we're getting
on the productivity gains of using something
like Dart for your Web applications is very,
very positive.
I will let this slide stay up for two more
seconds so you can read it.
>>Lars Bak: All right. Well, for me it is
good just to have a choice of another system,
if it fits your needs better.
But let's go a little bit deeper when it comes
to performance. I'd like to talk about why
we can make Dart faster than JavaScript. In
some cases, it already is.
Right. We are VM engineers. We have done that
for most of our professional lives. And we
designed Dart to make sure we could optimize
it. Maybe it is a little bit selfish, but
it is basically so we can get better performance.
So the language model, the language semantics,
is very simple in Dart. It has a much simpler
optic model.
It means that when you first have allocated
an optic with fields, you cannot change it
after the allocation point. That's it. And
it allows us to have much faster access to
fields, right? Just like in C# or in Java,
you can actually access the nth element because
you know that that is exactly where the foo
property is.
Programmers are declared so you don't have
to run Dart in order to set up the program
in contrast to JavaScript. That allows us
to use snapshots for having fast startup of
applications. We like that feature.
And then we just have fewer special corner
cases to worry about. As an example of a corner
case in JavaScript is that, well, you might
actually like it as a programmer that you
can call a method with too many parameters
or too few. Well, this is sort of nice but
in the implementation, somebody has to figure
out what you called it with and that costs,
right? And if you don't provide enough argument,
somebody has to provide them for you, the
underlying system. And stuff like that makes
the code more complicated to generate and
the resultant code is also more loaded.
Let's give an example. Here I tried to make
a side-by-side comparison between Dart and
JavaScript and what code it generates and
how it works. On the right side, you can see
that we have two classes. We have a class
A. It has a method called foo. It prints out
foo. And then we have a subclass B that inherits
from -- or extends A. It has nothing. And
you create a new B -- it is called b, lowercase
b. And the main function on the right, you
call foo. Very, very simple. We try to mimic
the same in JavaScript. You have to go to
the left of the screen. The way we model inheritance
in JavaScript is by using prototypes, so we
make a function A. And in the prototype of
A, we put in the foo function, just like on
the right.
And then we make a function B that calls constructor
A. And in the B prototype, we don't do anything.
We just set it to a new A and then we create
a new B and we call B. So it is sort of the
same. No difference.
The problem in JavaScript when it comes to
speed is you can actually on the fly change
the code. So in the inserter box you can see
that right there we actually are extending
the B pro type with a new foo that prints
in foo. You can call B foo again. And the
semantics is you have to print out new foo
now. We don't have that in Dart. We think
this is a plus. It is certainly a plus for
the implementation. So let's look at it. B
is the object created. That's the object we
wanted to execute foo on. It points to the
B prototype in JavaScript that, again, points
to the A prototype. When you start running
the program, you don't have the middle foo
so you have to execute the one up in A the
problem is, you don't know if somebody is
going to insert a foo going forward. The system
has to cope with it. So in V8 you have a choice.
Either you have to always validate. There
is no foo in the B prototype before you can
execute the one up in A. Then it will invalidate
the code, how it generated, with these assumptions.
The problem is, the B prototype is an ordinary
object. You do not want to put in a general
dependency system for normal objects. So in
Dart -- no, sorry, in JavaScript V8, we actually
validate that there's no foo in the middle
here before we execute foo in the A prototype.
That is expensive on the implementation side.
Let me try to show you what it cost in generator
code. So given the example we had on the previous
slide, we now have a small benchmark. It's
the micro benchmark. We don't like them, yes,
but I'm trying to make a point here. It's
a loop that just called B.foo repeatedly.
And I warm up that program and I look at what
the various system generates. On the left
side, you can see the result of what V8 generates.
It generates nearly 300 bytes of common code
and 239 bytes of stop code. The stop code
is the source. You need in order to optimization,
if something goes wrong, for instance, you
add the extra code in the middle. On the Dart
side, it's somewhat simpler. You can see the
optimized code here. It's much smaller. In
fact, it's only a third of the V8 code being
generated. So the simple semantics in the
programming language just makes sense, right?
It's much easier to make fast. Optimizing
a little bit of code is much easier than optimizing
a big piece of code. Generally, less code
is great. Better memory performance. You also
get predictable performance because you cannot
change the code after you start it up. So
keep it simple. It's good for us, V8.
>>Kasper Lund: Hopefully it's very good for
application developers that get more predictable
performance and just generally better performance.
So let's benchmark this thing with a non-micro
brashing benchmark suite. To benchmark the
Dart VM. We have used multiple. A couple that
are interesting are Richards and DeltaBlue.
That means that if we make Richards and DeltaBlue
faster, it will have an impact on a real web
application. So using benchmark that you -- that
have proven valuable in the context of other
languages makes a lot of sense, especially
if you want to try to bring a new programming
language implementation to the web and make
sure it has nice performance properties that
match existing real languages. So we've used
in the past for self, Strongtalk, V8, and
now we're using these two benchmarks for tuning
Dart. It's important to stress that these
benchmarks really measure the performance
of calling methods, memory allocation, and
all the things applications tend to spend
a lot of time in. So Richards is an interesting
benchmark. It's a kernel simulating benchmark
that spends a lot of time in calling small
methods and dispatching between different
objects in here. What you see on the graph
here is the Dart VM is on the graph. V8 is
there and DART to JS, which is the generated
code we get from compiling the Richards version
in Dart to JavaScript with our own Compiler
and running that on V8. So you have three
different runtime systems here in play that
execute the same benchmark. So the Dart VM
is the fastest, which is a nice thing. You
can see the V8 performance is getting better
but not at the same pace as the Dart VM. Bigger
is better here. V8 has tuned for this benchmark
since its inception. We started out with a
Richards benchmark and we have achieved a
lot of really cool speedups on these benchmarks
over the years. It means that V8 is fairly
good at optimizing for this kind of application
code and benchmark. The Dart VM is already
1.7 times faster than V8 generates way less
code when running the benchmark and much better
at executing that kind of code. The Dart to
JS code is a little bit behind. The handwritten
version of JavaScript that we use to tune
V8 and there's some extra checks going on
in there. Something we're improving over time
as you can see by the graph. But it's really
nice to see that over the last year, we have
been able to take the Dart VM from being a
fairly simple implementation of a fairly simple
language to being a really efficient implementation
of a fairly simple language. This also shows
on the DeltaBlue benchmark numbers. Here the
difference is even bigger. It's a factor of
2. DeltaBlue is a one-way constraint solver.
It spends time in allocating objects, constraints
and dispatcher on them. Again, it's a benchmark
that has been used for many different languages
and proven valuable in those context as well.
It's great to see that here the same story
repeats itself. The Dart VM is just a lot
faster than V8. Of course, it's also faster
than a version we compiled to JavaScript.
It's interesting to see that the Dart to JS
numbers here are actually faster than the
handwritten JavaScript. So the comparison
here is between handwritten JavaScript that
V8 executes, where we have tried to implement
DeltaBlue in a reasonable way in JavaScript.
And then the generated code, this is also
JavaScript, that we compiled from Dart code
and the reason why it's a little bit faster
here is because we can do some analysis while
compiling. We can do some inlining to help
V8 execute this a little bit more quickly.
We do expect this to be able to improve the
quality of the Dart to JS Compiler over time.
We're aiming for trying to be as fast as the
code you would have written by hand in JavaScript.
So but clearly, the Dart VM is faster in this
kind of thing.
It's important to stress that performance
is super important to us. It really, really
matters that you get a really scalable application
platform out of using Dart. Having said that,
I think it's important to point to the fact
that users of Dart are really finding that
in addition to getting good performance, they
also feel that their productivity increased.
Ali has written a really large font atlas
generation tool, Glyph3D. We get this feedback
fairly consistently, that people that use
Dart for building bigger things are very,
very happy with it.
>>Lars Bak: Thank you. Just to follow up on
what Kasper said, performance is fantastic
in Dart right now and it's getting better
over time. We have seen on the web the last
few weeks some examples where Dart is out
performing Java. We are super excited about
that. We hope to get up to that level for
almost all applications basically.
So the ultimate goal is to get the Dart VM
into Chrome. I hope you all agree. Exactly.
At least one.
[ Laughter ]
But we have a little bit of a problem here.
I sort of mentioned that the garbage collection
is story where the DOM was a little bit complicated
with these reference counts and stuff like
that. And putting Dart VM into the pit doesn't
make it easier. And we cannot convince ourselves
with reference counting that we can reclaim
all unused cycles or memory data structures
in the browser. That means memory leaks. We
really do not want that. So that's a problem.
But we like to do something about it. The
ohm way we can make sure that we do something
about it is to actually change the reference
counted nature of the DOM. And we create a
new project, started last month. It's called
Oilpan. It makes sure that it handles garbage
collection between the difference segments
inside Chrome and Blink. Which is JavaScript,
DOM, eventually Dart. We want to convert the
reference count in DOM into being traced so
we can trace through JavaScript ons, through
DOM nodes and through Dart nodes and make
sure we know what we have. The cool thing
about tracing is you can find all pointers
that point to an object. That means you can
move the object if you choose to do so. You
can even do [indiscernible] and start from
that point on. And if you are really brave,
we can start doing concurrent manipulation
of the DOM. So we hope this is all appealing
for us guys because it basically means we
get a much faster browser out of it and a
browser use less memory. One thing about the
con currency when you have reference counting
in the objects, you actually have to put in
a lock around it if you do concurrent access.
That's expensive. When you get a pointer to
an object, you have to lock, increment the
pointer, unlock again. That's not practical
when using reference counting. We can do all
this if unify the memory manager for playing.
We are excited about this project.
>>Kasper Lund: We feel like no presentation
is really done without a demo of some sort.
So lately we have been working on making Dart
even faster. No surprise there. A lot of modern
CPUs today support what is known as SIMD,
single instruction multi-data instructions,
where you have instructions on the CPU that
can operate on four floating point values
in parallel making it much, much faster. So
the Dart VM has been enhanced for support
for using those instructions and no other
web language has the support yet. It's very
nice to see this in action in a browser, just
making things faster. It's really useful for
3D calculations, image processing, audio processing.
We would like to show you a little demo of
Google Chrome with the Dart VM put in there
running a 3D animation thing with and without
the SIMD support to show you the significance
of this kind of work. So let's switch to the
other.
>>Lars Bak: So here we are running Dart VM
with a Blink with Dart VM. We have a bunch
of monsters. They all handle inside Dart.
So that means that the animation, the skeleton
positions and all that is happening inside
Dart. It's not on the GPU. And this is the
-- somebody is beeping. This benchmark has
been created so it is trying to always have
60 frames per second. If it runs too fast,
it will throw in more monsters. We have 34.
We can turn it on with using a flag down here.
Let's try it. SIMD. So this is using SIMD
in animation in Dart.
[ Applause ]
So a factor of three and a half is not too
bad, I guess. I'm really excited about this
and it actually gives you a lot more power
to do computation inside JavaScript. So this
is coming to you and I'm excited.
>>Kasper Lund: So let's conclude this presentation
so we have time for some questions. So we
are VM guys. We want to have a job moving
forward. We think performance is always interesting.
I hope you like that, too. And we hope we
have convinced you that if you really want
to spark more performance into the browser,
we need probably a different option than JavaScript.
I think Dart is one contender for that. The
Dart VM is already faster than JavaScript
and is approaching other programming languages
out there. Again, just to point it out again
that higher performance is great for application
developers. That's where you actually can
get head room to do more interesting stuff.
Right now, the core Dart platform is stable.
We will start using the SDK. That doesn't
mean it's inside Chrome. After we send out
1.0, that will be our main focus. Right now
you can see people on the web using Dart.
Some have written fairly large bodies of code
and they are happy with it. And inside Google
people have started using it. There's critical
projects start using Dart, hopefully we will
see some of these applications coming to you
soon. This will conclude our presentation.
We should go to questions.
[ Applause ]
>>Kasper Lund: If we are unable to answer
your questions here. We have other Dart questions
at Google I/O today. So if you have found
this inspiring and you want to see more on
more specific details, here's a list of things
in room -- mostly in room 6, I guess, where
you can see other Dart presentations here.
Yes?
>>Lars Bak: Let's get the first question.
>>> My question is slightly related to that
first one, coming from a GWT development background,
wondering if you have done any benchmarks
in comparison from the Dart to JavaScript
Compiler to the Java to JavaScript Compiler.
>>Lars Bak: I don't have any numbers for you.
It is easy to try out. DeltaBlue, it is free
to try out for yourself. One thing I would
like to see is that we are trying to go beyond
grit in that we are doing a native Dart VM
that can boost performance and reduce startup
time. This is really what we want to get at.
Especially for mobile platforms where loading
an application can be a dog and take many
resources. Faster VM, faster startup means
less battery. Next question, please.
>>> Hi. Have there been discussions of including
Dart in other browsers and if not, would it
be possible to add it through plug-ins?
>>Lars Bak: It will be fantastic to have all
browsers using Dart. Clearly people have strong
opinions when it comes to programming languages.
I don't really understand why but that's how
it is.
[ Laughter ]
I just want to make sure that people the right
tools to build the applications with. Our
system is completely open source. It has a
well-defined API. So when other browsers think
that this extra boost of performance will
be good for them, they can take it up and
we will be happy to help them out, basically.
So we are open for collaboration.
>>Kasper Lund: We have a few questions from
our online audience and maybe just try to
answer a few of them as well. I can cover
the second one. I think you covered the grit
question already. This question is about Android
studio. And if we are planning on releasing
something similar for Dart. In a sense we
already are releasing something similar for
Dart. We have a fully-featured Dart editor.
But in addition to that, and maybe this is
what the question is really about, we do have
support for using and working with Dart from
IntelliJ. It is here. If you are interested
in this kind of thing, definitely come talk
to them at the booth. So the short answer
is really that we are looking into releasing
all sorts of nice tools for Dart being based
both on Eclipse and IntelliJ. Definitely.
>>Lars Bak: Let's take the next question from
the audience.
>>> Hi. I have a bit of long -- seemingly
longstanding wisdom I got a few years ago
that occurs to me might be out of date which
is the idea -- this is about V8, that JavaScript
objects are going to be more performant if
you define prototype rather than defining
methods dynamically in a constructor. It occurs
to me with hidden, you have optimized it so
it wouldn't make a difference.
>>Lars Bak: We certainly try to. We tried
very hard to optimize in V8. But it's still
the case that you have to create a new class
whenever you add a property in a way you haven't
seen before. So you get a forest of classes
even for the same constructor. And in Dart,
you only have one format for one class whereas
in V8, right, depending on how you add properties
to an object from a given constructor, you
can get a sea of them. We have to cut off
at some point. We have limits inside V8. When
you reach a certain number of hidden classes
for constructer. We say, we actually just
-- we de-optimize now and we make sure that
objects will only be treated as maps and get
slow.
>>> So is it true that, then, prototype would
be more performant in V8 than using construct-defining
properties, even if you define them the same
way every time in constructor.
>>Lars Bak: I think it depends on exactly
the setup. You can make it so they perform
exactly the same. It really depends on how
the application adds properties to your object
on the fly.
>>Kasper Lund: Little bit of explanation.
V8 does try to move functions to the class
side so to share them behind the scenes anyway.
So you can say adding on the objects is sort
of optimize too, but it really depends on
the application if it makes a difference.
>>Lars Bak: Next question.
>>> One of the arguments for no JS is that
you have JavaScript everywhere, service side
even. Are you looking at Dart service side
or is there more momentum behind go.
>>Lars Bak: That's a great question. Of course,
we have that. So we have a service side library
you can use. You can use the Dart VM stand
alone if you want to. You can use the same
kind of ace synchronize size style as you
do in no JS. You saw the performance numbers
on the slide. This is a performance measurement
system we are using internally, all written
in Dart. It controls a lot of machines at
the same time we use exactly that server side
system. So, yes, we have a libraries for supporting
service side Dart execution but our main focus
right now is the client side and getting it
to Chrome.
>>Kasper Lund: I think we have time for one
more question. If you have more questions,
the large line, it will be at the office hours
booth so come to us and ask those questions
there. But let's take the final question.
>>> My question is there's a lot of JavaScript
code already there. Is there a tool, or even
if it is possible, to convert JavaScript into
Dart.
>>Kasper Lund: Generally we find that people
that try to rewrite existing code basis from
JavaScript or from other languages to Dart
are generally fairly successful. It's also
possible to use the JavaScript code from Dart
by wrapping it a little bit and using what
we called JavaScript interrupt. But generally
translating from JavaScript, unless you use
very, very dynamic features of JavaScript
a lot, it's actually recently easy. A lot
of people have good success with that.
>>> You guys have a tool.
>>Kasper Lund: There is no tool, no.
>>Lars Bak: Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]